someone were to truly objectively
evaluate turmeric okay I don't think
there's one condition one health problem
that you couldn't find some benefit from
taking this right here it's amazing I've
been growing turmeric for the last nine
months and I finally harvested it and my
wife and I are eating it and we're just
chewing it it's like an aromatic carrot
it's not very strong but boy does this
have some serious potent properties but
first let me talk about how to increase
the bioavailability of turmeric now
anytime you take turmeric in a
supplement I highly recommend you don't
take it in the curcumin extract only you
want the whole plant because curcumin is
only one of many many and I'm talking
about thousands of different
phytonutrients in turmeric so if you get
something that says curcumin extract
also make sure it comes with the
turmeric powder or you could just like I
said before chew the whole thing number
two black pepper paper or white pepper
will help you increase the absorption by
roughly two thousand percent the white
pepper actually increases the absorption
a little bit better but they're both
pretty similar now what you could do if
you're going to take a supplement or
just consume this you can just take a
black peppercorn or a white peppercorn
and this swallow it that will help and
thirdly add some fat at the same time
you're consuming it the question is why
because a lot of these phytonutrients
including curcumin are fat soluble so in
order to better absorb them you need
some fat you can do ghee you can do
butter MCT oil coconut oil olive oil any
of the fats just a little bit now the
other thing to know is that these
phytonutrients are a bit heat sensitive
so if you're gonna put them in your
Foods chances are they're not going to
be as potent the other point is if you
get a supplement with turmeric or the
curcumin extract make sure you get the
one that's freeze dry right because
freeze-dried allows for these enzymes to
be activated so they're in a state
that's dormant but they're not overly
processed or heated so let's just do a
deep dive into what this stuff actually
can do for your body out of all the
plants I would imagine that turmeric is
right at the very top as far as the
number of studies that were done on this
I'm talking about double blinded
placebo-controlled studies on all sorts
of things the two big areas of research
for turmeric are number one inflammation
and number two cancer and the amazing
thing about turmeric is that it has
virtually no side effects there's been
no deaths no serious side effects maybe
some slight digestive problems if you
have too much but even at high doses
there's no major serious side effects
like there are with medications and
they've compared a lot of different
medications to turmeric and turmeric
keeps up with these medication effects
okay so let's start with antioxidant
potential it increases glutathione it
increases other antioxidant networks in
your body by actually increasing your
ability to activate these antioxidants
there are certain genes that turn on or
turn off your antioxidants and turmeric
has the ability to turn them on to help
fight off free radical damage that's
involved with oxidation and inflammation
turmeric also has potent effects for
your brain and nervous system it's been
tested to show significant improvements
Alzheimer's Parkinson's other
neurodegenerative disorders it's also
been shown to decrease the formation of
plaquing in the brain it has very potent
cardiovascular effects and helping
lowering blood pressure decreasing
lipids help slowing down the formation
of plaquing in arterial sclerosis and
clogged arteries it also protects that
inner lining of your arteries the
endothelial layer that is usually most
vulnerable to inflammation now from a
microbe standpoint turmeric is a
powerful anti-microbial antiviral
antibacterial anti-candida anti-fungal
antiparasitic anti-h pylori so it's
great to take if someone had an
infection it shows great benefits to
dermatitis and many other skin problems
psoriasis it's great for the liver too
to protect the liver against fat
formation fibrosis which someone
develops after they have inflammation in
the liver because turmeric has very
potent anti-inflammatory properties it's
going to slow down fibrosis certain
things in turmeric also increase bile
salts and that gives you a whole Cascade
of improving digestion increasing the
fat soluble vitamins turmeric helps
support the gut mucosal lining and
that's really important to prevent
autoimmune diseases allergies and immune
deficiencies curcumin in turmeric
directly targets the DNA to help protect
the DNA against free radical damage to
help in the Improvement and repair of
DNA it also helps the cells that are
damaged commit suicide and that's a good
thing it's called apoptosis which is
controlled a cell death if there's a
problem in the cell which that right
there can help lessen the risk for
cancer curcumin also protects the cell
if someone is taking chemo or radiation
therapy as well as increasing the
effectiveness of that treatment turmeric
also helps the endocrine system in many
different ways one big way is to make
insulin more sensitive so if someone has
insulin resistance as a pre-diabetic or
a diabetic it helps insulin become more
sensitive there's been quite a few
studies and I'm talking about like
clinical trials that are double-blinded
placebo-controlled studies showing
protection against a pre-diabetic going
in to a diabetic also at the same time
diabetics taking this greatly reduce the
complications from diabetes so even
though they have diabetes they have a
lot less side effects also turmeric
shows great therapeutic benefits in
being an adaptogen which is something to
help you increase your tolerance against
stress this has also been used to help
depression anxiety so it can help both
mood disorders as well as cognitive
disorders but like I said before cancer
and inflammation are the two primary
things that turmeric is known for
there's a lot of research in many
different types of cancers not only
directly targeting the cancer but
inhibiting a lot of the mechanisms that
are involved with cancer including
inhibiting angiogenesis which is feeding
blood flow to the cancer countering some
of the mechanisms that cancer and tumor
cells use to suppress your own immune
system so it actually helps your cells
prevent the cancer cell from surviving
and also in one study they found
curcumin inside a colon cancer cell
which means that somehow it ended up
there which is a good thing because now
that can create some really cool effects
there's many different Pathways involved
with inflammation and so curcumin seems
to inhibit most of those Pathways which
gives a very broad spectrum approach for
inflammation I'll include one study that
shows all the different medications that
work for inflammation and then how
curcumin mimics a lot of these
medications and so curcumin is not
actually a root it's a rhizosome which
is kind of like a the stem of a plant
that lives underneath the soil to help
protect it and like I said before it's
it's not bad but if you're not growing
it just go to the grocery store go ahead
and buy some organic and just eat two or
three of these per day to prevent a lot
of problems
hmm
delicious